What creatures will you meet when you go
see the new movie Dungeons and Dragons
honor among Thieves
oh that's not good
will there be an album
what is that again the mashup that
somehow carries all of the terror with
none of the cute from owls and bears
we're mimics monsters that composes
anything
will there be a gelatinous cube that
disarms its victims how about a
displacer beast a predator with
tentacles and cloaking abilities and
well isn't that more than enough
oh an intellect Devourer a giant brain
that consumes other brains like some
kind of awful brain cannibal the higher
the intelligence the prey the more
likely they are to strike
oh that's a little hurtful or even
member shot the red dragon who looks
like he ate all the other dragons as
appetizers
you'll just have to go see Dungeons and
Dragons honor among Thieves to find out
foreign